2016 war ein extrem beschissenes jahr
oder wie man bei der spd sagt alles wie
immer wir sagen danke 2016 danke für gar
nichts wie war denn ihr 2016 gut gut
sehr schön sehr gut ich würde sagen
super durchweg positiv udo sträter ein
sehr gutes jahr gut sehr schön
donald trump listings krise war es
wirklich alles so toll
also wir fangen wir mal ab wie weit es
geht nicht immer nur um sie
entschuldigung
sie haben da was im haar ein bisschen
was war 2016 die schlimmere meldung
sarah und pietro lombardi sind
auseinander oder sarah und pietro
lombardi sind wieder zu haben
uninteressant so was das ist keine
meldungen das ist das einfach nur
uninteressant wie als sehr berührt recht
ist ein armer menschen die so was
berührt zusammen
2016 war das jahr in dem die lüge auch
erfolge gefeiert hat was war 2016 ihre
lieblings lüge a ich hab das nicht
gepostet
b ich habe nichts gegen ausländer aber
zäh schatz ich muss heute länger
arbeiten die ich liebe dich lachen ist
immer sehr aufwendig
es gehört sich nicht haben wir keine
chance
dann greift auch gar keine null zero na
ja wir können nichts dafür
[Musik]
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge aus durch ein
wenig ändern
vielleicht auch ganz gut dass wir die
engländer los sind oder aber ist doch so
nochmal das wird noch mal sagen dürfen
es sind auch nur menschen
[Musik]
worum beneiden sie donald trump mehr um
seine macht oder um seine frau weder
noch alles klischee sagte donald trump
hatte einen eher kleinen definitiv wenn
so was meine erfahrung betrifft vom
äußerlichen kann ich es bestimmt
bestätigen dass er die amerikaner leiten
das von den händen ab donald trump hat
sehr kleine hände
ja ich habe sehr große also ich glaube
ich wir wissen ja die leute sind alle
total zufrieden offenbar war das hier
alles ein großes missverständnis 2016
war wollen total geil is ja insofern
hoffe ich es geht genauso weiter 2017
[Applaus]